so right now
if a promoter hits you 40 racks 40 racks
that's a concert what if somebody wants
you to come and do one song at the club
now how about this i'ma present it this
way
they want you to do one song in the club
but it's a market where you're
lit i'll pop up a pop out come and do
the record at the dj booth yeah for half
okay
all right
but you you know what what's crazy i
appreciate about you is like
i know that you know that it ain't like
that everywhere no it ain't so if it's
some random ass market where you're like
man i'm trying to get in front of some
new people i'm gonna do it for free
that's crazy i ain't gonna cap like to
this day like if i know i ain't turned
in the market i'm i'm not and i gotta be
in that [ __ ] i'm doing it for free if
it's a market where i'm lit at come on i
gotta mix
of course i can go get some money from
any promoter in this market but if it's
some [ __ ] where i ain't
[ __ ] ain't really hip to my
music i gotta go regardless so if it's
just this just speeding that process up
i just got a free flight to this
[ __ ] free travel free room yeah
bring my team go campaign in a new city
exactly i gotta do it free i don't think
like that i really don't move for money
bro i really don't